this is the way me too ends this is the
way me too ends this is the way hashtag
me too ends not with a bang but a
whimper we will discuss Hollow Men the
sodden women and the neo of Victorian
morality then this day in history
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Noel's show
[Music]
there is so much to get to this is one
of the most interesting cultural stories
that we've seen in a year or more before
we get to that a little bit of
bookkeeping in case you missed it
yesterday or you might be interested in
seeing it Ben and I went over to our
friend Tai Lopez's house last night
Tai lobe you might you might know him he
had one of the biggest ads on YouTube
ever I think this is Tai just bought
this new Lamborghini here fun to drive
up here in the Hollywood Hills but you
know what I like a lot more than
materialistic things knowledge in fact
I'm a lot more proud of these seven new
bookshelves that I had to get installed
to hold 2,000 new books that I bought
it's like the billionaire Warren Buffett
says the more you learn the more you
earn I love that ad that's the guy you
know I'm here in my garage with my
Lamborghini and all my books and
everything so and this is a really
bizarre coincidence
two of the first people that I met in LA
right when I got out here we're Ty and
Ben so really totally randomly I just
come in to LA for some auditions friend
of mine that I was staying with said
I'll go to the cigar bar I have some
work to do for a couple hours so I go to
this cigar bar down the street I'm
reading a book just smoking a cigar guy
turns to me he's reading a book he says
you're the first guy I've seen reading a
book in LA we should be friends and
which is true and more I've lived here
the more I've learned that and so anyway
it turned out that he was living up with
Tai Lopez's house this internet guru
you know reads a book a day kind of guy
and so the invited me up to a party
there a couple days later so my first
taste of LA was hanging out with with
those guys and obviously I met Ben
through Andrew Klavan and Jeremy boring
and the whole daily wire crew so this is
a real melding of the worlds Ben did I
think an hour-long podcast with Ty that
I came in I did an hour-long podcast
with Ty so if you want to check those
out there were over on all of his social
media platforms there's a lot of fun
especially hanging out in his house
which i think is worth a gazillion
dollars so there's a nice change of pace
from my cardboard box that i live in
down in Culver City
so anyway go check it out it's a lot of
fun before we get into today's show we
have to thank some
because look I we only have about 45
minutes that we can get into this show
today at most and if you're a person if
you if you want to be able to read a
book a day and plan out your life and
get a twenty seven gazillion dollar home
you got to make sure you get your
appointments up on time that you keep a
schedule how are you gonna do that right
there baby movement watches movement
watches was founded on the belief that
style shouldn't break the bank the
watchmakers goal is to change the way
consumers think about fashion by
offering high-quality minimalist prod
products at revolutionary prices so I
love watches I have a bunch of watches
but I refuse to pay thousands of dollars
for a really high-end timepiece I won't
even pay you know hundreds of dollars if
you go into a department store you want
to get a watch that looks like this and
is the same quality is this you're gonna
be looking at three four maybe five
hundred dollars movement watches has
circumvented all of that by going
straight to the consumer so they've sold
over a million watches that way to
customers in a 160 plus countries around
the world and movement has solidified
itself as the fastest-growing watch
company in the world so you know I use
this one I really like this this is one
of the chrono watches it's a little you
know it's it's a little bulkier on the
wrist it's a more solid watch it has
some of the you know stop watches and
those kind of things I really like this
a little sporty err but they have a ton
of great stuff I really love the
revolver collection that one is a little
bit more on the dressier side a little
more throw back a little less sporty
really whatever kind of watch you want
you can get it there and you get it at
the fraction of the cost of watches and
department stores so you can get more
than one and every man should wear a
watch women should wear watches too it
just shows that you have places to go
people to see you're not always checking
your cell phone like you're a little
toddler or something you can't always
have to pull it out of your pocket
that's a hassle be an adult wear a watch
you know they start at just 95 dollars
so that's an unbelievable price point
under 100 bucks you can get one of these
watches it's because selling online they
can cut out the middleman and all of
that retail markup so you get the best
possible price directly to you it's got
a classic design quality construction
styled minimalism
so now I know that I said that they cost
they started $95 you can get 15% off
today so it'll be even cheaper and you
can get free shipping and you can get
free returns there's no risk whatsoever
so you go to movement calm
that's MV MT calm because we don't have
time for vowels this is the modern world
baby we got to get moving
MVM t calm / co f f/a co v fe fe m vm t
calm / co f f/a co v fe fe what is a
marshall co v fe fe this watch has
really clean design it is it's really
nice you know everyone around here wears
them and you get a lot of complements
they're really cool watches so come on
step up your watch game this is 2018 new
year new you get a movement watch mbm t
icon / cough fa Co V Fe Fe join the
movement
alright let's get into this let's get
into the main story the me to campaign
the hashtag me to campaign about sexual
assault and harassment has officially
jumped the shark we talked about this a
little bit at the end yesterday with
Alicia but the fallout from this piece
is even more interesting really than the
piece itself the feminist website babe
calm gotta love it they were in a piece
yesterday
titled I went on a date with disease I'm
sorry it turned into the worst night of
my life
the worst night of her life Wow clearly
this is going to be a Weinstein esque
tale of abuse rape intimidation
blacklisting enormity right these
accusations are so bad
the accuser chose to remain anonymous
going only by the emotionally evocative
pseudonym grace so what does the accuser
allege happened she alleges that she hit
on Aziz Ansari the left-wing comedian at
an Emmys afterparty
he ignored her but nevertheless she
persisted they exchanged numbers that
was that she heads back across the
country to New York he leaves her a
voicemail and they chat via text for
about a week now that part seems minimal
we'll get to why that's a key aspect of
the problem here a little bit later so
they said a de grâce agonizes with her
friends over what to wear these jeans
yada yada
blah blah blah she arrives at his
apartment and here's where things go
horribly horribly wrong did he attack
her no did he take her captive no no no
instead he offered her white wine
instead of red I'm serious babe calm
writes quote after arriving at his
apartment in Manhattan on Monday evening
they exchanged small talk and drank wine
it was white she said I didn't get to
choose but I prefer red but it was a
white wine then I'm sorry walked her to
grand banks an oyster bar on board a
historic wooden shoe neuron the Hudson
River just a few blocks away I actually
used to live right around that area can
you imagine the horror her host her date
offered her the type of wine preferred
by virtually every woman on earth
without even taking one moment to become
a psychic and read her mind and
understand that she likes the other kind
of wine before buying her dinner at an
expensive oyster bar lock him up lock
him up cold up Marshall can you get the
police on the line this is how rages so
they had dinner and then Ansari checked
asked for the check so babe writes grace
says she sensed ansari was eager for
them to leave when the waiter came over
he quickly asked for the check and he
said like let's get off this boat she
recalls there was still wine in her
glass and even more left in the bottle
he ordered the abruptness surprised her
like he got the check and then it was
bada-boom bada-bing we're out of there
that's right that's right you heard that
correctly Ansari was too quick to pay
for their expensive dinner the classic
faux pas you're at a dinner and your
date pays the pill too quickly isn't
that's a tale as old as time just
terrible so anyway they go back to his
apartment they flirt for a little bit
they get naked and they make out as babe
tells it she remembers feeling
uncomfortable at how quickly things
escalated note the wording here grace
doesn't remember expressing her
discomfort in any way
she doesn't remember telling him that
they should keep their clothes on or not
to kiss her she just felt it I just felt
it now things get really crazy Aziz
Ansari allegedly tried to have sex
with the naked lady in his apartment and
they almost did it can you believe it
they both made it to third base as it
were and then she finally told him
firmly she didn't want to have sex so
they stopped and sat on the couch
then she started how do I say this on a
family friendly show she gave him
another triple they kissed some more now
keep in mind they're still completely
naked at this point then she changed her
mind again and said she didn't want to
have sex and she put her clothes back on
and she said you guys are all the same
you guys are all at that effing same
truer words by the way have you ever
been spoken and that is a major aspect
of this but we'll get back to that in a
second so she calls a cab and she leaves
here's the most important line grace
explains it took a really long time for
me to validate this as sexual assault I
was debating if this was an awkward
sexual experience or sexual assault as a
rule if you have to ask it's the former
not the latter if you have to debate it
it's the former it's not sexual assault
at no point in this entire encounter the
disease unser recommit sexual assault
and that pains me to say because I don't
really like Aziz Ansari at all I don't
find him funny
I think his political preening is like
nails on a chalkboard and the character
he plays on stage is an all around SOI
boy but this is a classic case of regret
not assault and that doesn't mean the
girl doesn't have a right to be sad or
hurt or angry she felt used because she
was being used what why did the girls
stick around at all after the the awful
wine episode at the beginning why did
she stick around because she liked
Ansari and she wanted him to like her
for more than her body for more than
just a one or two nights stand for more
than just sex
now Ansari may have liked her he may
have just wanted to score I don't know
but like all men and especially famous
men and especially rich famous men and
especially rich influential famous men
most especially of all like rich
influential famous men in a hookup
culture that treats sex like a handshake
he wanted sex and he expected it to come
easy because that's our culture that's
the ubiquitous culture surrounding sex
that we live in but why did she stick
around if she felt uncomfortable why did
she strip naked and keep engaging in sex
acts why did she repeatedly let him make
it
for around the bases we have an answer
from sexpert April Mazzini yes sex Bert
that's a thing sex Bert
if sex Bert April Mazzini of asked April
dot-com explains quote I hear from women
who have sex on the first date and then
try to leverage that act into love they
impute their feelings about the sex on a
first date on to the other person and
those who feel that sex on a first date
means interest or often hurt if a second
date doesn't evolve a tale as old as
time but a trick not always so pervasive
and relied upon 46 percent of people who
use the dating website OkCupid say
they'd sleep with someone on the first
date a high percentage that just keeps
rising in recent years and OkCupid is a
pretty good source here because online
dating sites and mobile apps like
Tyndall Tindall tinder or a Bumble or
whatever you know and in my single days
I always used Grindr but I never met the
right lady they had they always had
these huge Adam's apples that with just
neither here nor there the use of online
dating sites and mobile apps among young
people nearly tripled just between 2013
and 2015 according to Pew Research and
there isn't a ton of research available
for how that trend has evolved even over
the past three years I but I can tell
you from personal interaction see and
you know it yourselves every single
young person in the country is on these
apps I have multiple friends who even
met their future wives on these apps I'm
going to go to two weddings this spring
as a matter of fact four friends who met
on apps like tinder still marriage is
the exception not the rule
when it comes to all of these apps and
these websites the trouble with these
apps is that they incentivize a swipe
right culture where the next better
hookup is always a click away why stick
with the person you've got the person
sitting across from you or in the bar or
at the party or whatever when your phone
is buzzing with an endless stream of new
digital hotties buzz buzz buzz that gets
back to one of the earliest aspects of
Aziz and this girl's encounter one that
everybody's missing in their coverage
they met at a party she hits on him he's
not that interested that chat a little
bit they exchanged numbers then what
happens they text for a week they text
they don't grab coffee or a drink they
don't even talk on the phone they text
and texts can be a deceptive experience
what we know that she's interested
where the texts flirty yeah presumably
what did they say what what did she say
to him how did he respond texts are a
virtual fantasy land there's no phone to
hear the tone or the tenor or the
hesitations in someone's voice there's
no face staring you down to seduce or to
embarrass or to shame or to amuse or do
anything texts are a blunt object but
increasingly through the only way that
single Millennials communicate a 2014
Gallup poll and now we're talking four
years ago a full 68 percent of 18 to 29
year olds reported that they had texted
quote a lot the previous day that number
plunges to 47% among 30 to 49 year olds
and down to 26% of 50 to 64 year olds
and 0% of me because I hate texting I
hate I hate I really you know I'm
Marshall I do not text I despise it I
find it here's the reason I find it so
rude when you're having a conversation
with somebody to look down and check
your phone and start talking to somebody
else hold on a second no I I know we're
having a conversation but literally
anything else on planet Earth is more
interesting than what you're saying to
me so let me pull out my phone spin the
roulette wheel and assume whatever is on
that screen is more important than you I
hate it I don't do it and then I don't
later on so I don't do it in the moment
and I don't even do it later on when I
stop talking to somebody aside from that
digression everybody texts and texting
dehumanizes the person on the other end
it abstracts that person it removes
every single sense of another person
other than seeing a formalized
abstraction of their thought in the form
of words on a screen and maybe a weird
picture or two that's it it's not even
like writing a letter a long letter
where you get a sense of their feelings
it's just three words this that this the
other thing it's very shallow so even
heading into the date Azeez and this
woman head in with necessarily different
perceptions and likely different
expectations and then we equate Harvey
Weinstein's violently raping women and
ruining their careers and blackmailing
them with an awkward date and consensual
sexual encounter that left a woman upset
because a man wanted to have sex in a
culture where sex on the first date is
common and basically expected in a
culture that
tells you men and women are exactly the
same the sexes are indiscernible they
want exactly the same things
professionally personally and sexually a
culture were two people could enter an
encounter in good faith with exactly the
same premises and yet one leaves hurt
and one leaves confused what's the
problem I'm a feminist I'm a feminist
I'm a feminist I just said a disease you
said oh that's a great point Joshi
Hermann the editor of babe calm said we
would publish this again tomorrow
the the piece about this awful encounter
with the wine and whatever it's
newsworthy because of who he is and what
he has said in his stand-up what he has
written in his book what he has
proclaimed on late-night TV her account
is pointing at a striking tension
between those things and the way she
says Aziz treated her in private now
this is actually sort of a decent point
why is it I'm a feminist I'm a feminist
I'm a feminist oh yeah right again Aziz
good job but that's it's not just that
the things he's spouting in public
contradict the things he does in private
it's that the things he's spouting in
public contradict the things that
everybody does in private because
feminism presents an incorrect view of
the world that men and women are exactly
the same and that hurts everybody
involved but perhaps the craziest thing
about this whole episode this pathetic
end to the me2 movement is that it's got
me agreeing with the Atlantic and the
New York Times that's awful
Caitlyn Flanagan writes in the Atlantic
quote she tells us that she wanted
something from Ansari and that she was
trying to figure out how to get it she
wanted affection kindness attention
perhaps she hoped to maybe even become
the famous man's girlfriend he wasn't
interested what she felt afterward
rejected yet another time by yet another
man was regret and what she and the
writer who told her story created was
3,000 words of revenge porn I thought it
would take a little longer for the hit
squad of privileged young white women to
open fire on brown-skinned men I had
assumed that on the basis of
intersectionality and all that they'd
stay laser focused on college-educated
white men for another few months but
we're at warp speed now and the
revolution in many ways so good and so
important is starting to sweep up all
sorts of people into its con
raishin the monstrous the cruel and the
simply unlucky apparently there is a
whole country full of young women who
don't know how to call a cab and who
have spent a lot of time picking out
pretty outfits for dates they hoped
would be nice to remember they're angry
and temporarily powerful and last night
they destroyed a man who didn't deserve
it Wow
absolutely right Kaitlyn Flanagan is
probably the best writer in the Atlantic
and it she's one of the reasons I still
subscribe to the Atlantic and by bizarre
coincidence I actually found out just
the other day she's Andrew Clavin
sister-in-law she's Druce the Drew's
wife's sister and I I suppose that isn't
coincidental that I would enjoy the
writing of Drew's sister-in-law but
still very small world she's exactly
correct she's brutally correct Barry
Weiss in the New York Times writes I am
a proud feminist and this is what I
thought well reading Grace's story if
you're hanging out naked with a man it's
safe to assume he's going to try to have
sex with you if the inability to choose
a pinot noir over a pinot grigio offends
you you can leave right then and there
if you don't like the way your date
hustles through paying the check you can
say I've had a lovely evening and I'm
going home now
if you go home with him and discover
he's a terrible kisser say I'm out if
you start to hook up and don't like the
way he smells or the way he talks or
doesn't talk and if he pressures you to
do something you don't want to do use a
four letter word stand up on your two
legs and walk out the door Aziz Ansari
sounds like he was aggressive and
selfish and obnoxious that night isn't
it heartbreaking and depressing that men
especially ones who present themselves
publicly as feminists often act this way
in private shouldn't we try to change
our broken sexual culture proud feminist
huh is that feminism Weiss is saying men
and women want different things from sex
that's perfectly fine for men to pick up
the check at dinner it's not
disrespectful or patriarchal it's
perfectly reasonable for men to choose a
wine and pour their data glass of it
though of course she may refuse it she's
right that there's a broken sexual
culture but the sexual culture is
feminist you can't simultaneously say
that the sexual culture begun 60 years
ago by feminism and sexual liberation is
broken and that's why we need more
feminism and sexual liberation we're
headed toward a neo Victorian era you
can see it all around you you see it on
college campuses which are now hiring
deans and deputy deans and deaf
assistant deputy Dean's to regulate and
monitor sexual activity the sort of
campus sexual regulation we haven't seen
since men and women had to sign back
into their single sex dorm rooms at
night however many decades ago the era
of original Victorian morality began
after the post Cromwell restoration of
the monarchy in England and led to a
period of free living and all-around
debauchery modeled after the French of
course a more libertine people you know
have never graced this earth so Queen
Victoria's uncle George the fourth was
popularly seen as a pleasure-seeking
playboy scandal abounded national
leaders were regularly seen as decadent
Playboy's the culture was freewheeling
and fun does that sound familiar now
what followed was a period of strict
morals personal restraint and cultural
ascendance we may be headed there now
but Victorian values were based in
traditional Victorian in traditional
Christian values until Charles Darwin
and the crisis of faith began eating
away at them the quality of the new
Victorianism we're heading toward will
be decided by precisely which moral
system which view of the world we
grounded in so you better start praying
ok can we get to this day in history now
we do know we can because we have to
sign off
Marshall you tyrant you monster I'm
sorry if you're on Facebook and YouTube
you got to go to Daley wire com if you
were already there and a subscriber
thank you you help us keep the lights on
and cafe in my cup and subscriptions to
the Atlantic for the one good article at
half a year if not please go to Daley
wire calm right now why why would you do
it well you'll get me you'll get the end
replayed and show you got the Ben
Shapiro show no ads on the website blah
blah blah the conversation you can ask
different questions
I think Druce conversation is today
actually at 2:15 is it Marshall yeah we
can hear him setting up in the room next
door so actually subscribe right this
second and you'll be able to ask Andrew
Clavin questions today for the
conversation it's gonna be really good
but the most important thing forget all
that the leftist tears tumblr this is
gonna be a big one folks the me2
movement is completely over now it's
ended with a
with a bat not with a bang but a whimper
feminism is being brought into question
because of our new cultural moment and
our new neo Victorianism you've got
Hollywood falling apart because of this
issue get it or you gonna drown
don't be stupid you're gonna drown on
salty salty delicious leftist ears you
can only drink so many you can only
gorge yourself on so many you have to
store them in a proper vessel like this
make the right decision for you and your
family and save yourselves go to daily
wire.com right now we'll be right back
[Music]
[Music]
okay let's get to this day in history
this day in history this is a big one on
this day in history the Roman Empire
officially began now I'm not going to go
through the entirety of the Roman Empire
in our last you know a few minutes here
so let's focus on one incredible
historical coincidence at the outset of
the Roman Empire that might shed some
light on the nature of the world of the
physical world in the metaphysical world
the Roman Empire began when Gaius Julius
Caesar
Octavius a a v n'j is frequently cold
air to the assassinated Julius Caesar
was granted the title augustus by the
Roman Senate
so Augustus ruled from January 16th 27
BC until its death in AD 14 after the
demise of the second triumvirate which
was formed by himself Mark Anthony and
Marcus Lepidus to defeat the assassins
of Julius Caesar Augustus restored the
semblance of the Roman Republic there
was the Senate and the legislators and
all that the semblance of it in reality
he retained firm rule for himself
there's much to note about Augustus but
consider just this one fact Augustus was
not actually the son of Caesar he was
his adopted son he was regularly
referred to as d-v filius son of a god
because upon julius caesar's death a
comet known as caesar's comment appeared
above the earth it was the brightest
comet in recorded history having even a
negative absolute magnitude it could be
seen even by daylight and was taken as a
sign that caesar had been deified turned
into a god upon his death and so the son
of a god rained on a throne in rome and
initiated the PAC's agustí the Peace of
Augusta the Peace of Rome of so much of
the civilized world that blanketed the
land
I was so named by Seneca the younger and
considered a miracle because of the
widespread war which had wreaked havoc
for so many centuries prior at that same
time during that same reign another
bright light appeared in the sky over
Bethlehem to signal precisely
the coming of another king a king whose
kingdom is not of this world a king who
would be called not Phileas DB but
Phileas day not son of a god or the
divinity but son of the one true God
himself and a king who would bring not
just peace for a time and a space but
for all time and space into eternity a
coincidence so incredible an example of
God's wimzie's so undeniable and yet
it's almost never taught in history
class or physics class or astronomy
class Alexander Pope put it well all
nature is but art unknown to the all
chance Direction which thou canst not
see that's our show today I'm Michael
Mills this is the Michael Knoll show we
are not gonna be here tomorrow I've got
a film shoot that I've got to be at
tomorrow because shockingly and
incredibly occasionally I still get
hired as an actor in this town but I
assume that'll be the last time so don't
worry about it again so we're gonna do a
show on Friday instead we're still gonna
do the mailbag on Thursday so get your
questions in ASAP and until Thursday
I'm Michael Knowles and I'll see you
then
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
Marshall Benson executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey supervising producer
mathis Glover our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex Zangaro
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua ov era the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018